live look at the campaign trail and
terry mcauliffe is at the mic he's got a
few more days to make his case to
virginia voters as another poll shows
that this race is in a virtual dead heat
just under a week to go now mcauliffe
and republican glenn yonkin less than
half a point apart at around
45 percent each in the suffolk
university usa today poll the same poll
shows president biden's approval rating
in virginia underwater by 11. this is a
state that he won by 10
last year that's a huge move in his
approval rating in just nine months the
president campaigned with mcauliffe who
mcauliffe said you know the president's
a little unpopular here in virginia but
he went there and campaigned anyway and
it's a race obviously that everybody's
watching to see take the temperature of
the nation in this microcosm of virginia
as we look towards the midterms for 2022
and who better to do this with than
america's news and co-anchor bill hemmer
who is dusted off the big board it's
shiny and new and ready to go for the
new election season and he'll be with us
on our election coverage on tuesday
night hey bill martha good afternoon to
you got a couple different models here
this is the studio f model okay and
made it just for you as a matter of fact
uh here's what we did this is the
governor result from four years ago in
2017.
ralph northam beat ed gillespie fairly
handily i'd say eight nine points right
there
i think as you look virginia it
over the past 12 years it's been a
fascinating state just to see the way
the demographics have changed and also
just where the political leanings have
gone in 2009 this governor's race was
won by a republican and now it's gone
well pretty much toward the democrats
for the past several cycles here's what
i do martha this is washington dc right
over here this is arlington just that
little speck right there just that
little area here provides a ton of votes
here for democrats right now and that's
where
president biden was just last night this
is louden county or so much about the
education push
watch this county on tuesday night see
whether or not young king can start to
chop into that that blue lead right
there in loudoun county but a lot of
votes up here
young king was with us earlier today
dana miller early in our program on
america's newsroom he was way down here
in franklin county where you see the the
advantage republicans have anyone at the
roanoke county you see again the
republican edge there over here to
pulaski county not as many votes down
here in this part of virginia clearly
but yet you know when you're talking
about a turnout election trying to drive
up those numbers a lot of these votes
will matter down here in the
southwestern part we see so much red
martha i i would put a focus here
on richmond virginia i've talked to a
lot of these experts who watch all the
polling in the state of virginia they're
saying this area right now is a toss-up
okay so why is that this is richmond
city clearly a democratic
heart bed right there for um
for the blue team i would say but you
get in rico county just north of it
things start to change a little bit then
you go to chesterfield county you get to
the suburbs and things are really pretty
dead even martha remember
when eric cantor was upset in his
congressional race well this is virginia
seven right here runs from south to
north and um
this was won by abigail spanberger two
years uh
three years ago now but she won her race
both times by only two points a real
thin margin there's a lot of talk right
now that this area is something that you
want to watch on tuesday night to try
and figure out well maybe how are things
going
um
is the state now shifting back toward
the red zone uh that that's something
really we're going to keep in mind here
and and i would say to martha we looked
at this earlier today this is where we
were just 11 months ago look at this now
all right you got biden and trump
they're separated by 10 points i mean
this was a walk away for democrats but
today you're at 4646 in the suffolk poll
between mcauliffe and yunkin and among
independents remember we talked about
this number last week independence
youngkin has an 11 point advantage in
this suffolk poll uh we're gonna have a
poll coming out later in this week here
and we'll see which way we see it i'm
gonna move over here right now uh and
we'll just finish up our conversation
here so i think all of that holds a lot
of intrigue and i just there one more
number out there you talked about joe
biden being underwater in virginia right
now
they did a right track wrong track in
virginia on that same poll 66 percent of
those in virginia say they're on the
wrong track
yeah and if you're terry mccall if
you're looking at you're thinking what
two-thirds of the people in my state
think we're going in the wrong direction
when joe biden came in last night and
said we're going in the right direction
that goes right to things like the
economy and how people feel about the
state of health in virginia today
economy is number one issue for voters
in virginia close behind his education
which we've been watching and glenn
younkin seized on that moment when terry
mcauliffe said you know parents
shouldn't be telling school boards how
to educate their children
and junk and i think rightfully jumped
on that whether or not he can pull it
out in virginia which as you point out
has been pretty deep blue over the past
decade or so tuesday night really
interesting to watch that could be a
long night we'll see honestly we'll be
there as usual with brett thank you very
much phil great to see you i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm ainsley
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis